so this Russia's invasion of Ukraine
over 200 buildings have been damaged or
destroyed with no end in sight for the
war people are working to salvage and
protect the country's cultural identity
curators are moving collections out of
the country and volunteers are working
to protect digital archives from cyber
attacks some have downloaded terabytes
worth of cloud-based servers for
academics to store their archives
outside of the country others are
collecting photographs and articles to
build a data set of the destruction
local preservation is also supported by
Ukraine's robust Tech Center The Project
UA damage aims to use neural network
algorithms to analyze the extent of
damage to a building by using satellite
and drone images they plan to have all
of Ukraine analyzed by the end of winter
Ukrainian Cultural identity has overcome
a lot of suppression from as early as
the 19th century under the Russian
Empire when the Ukrainian language was
banned to the removal of the letter G
from the alphabet in the Soviet times
that's why preserving these cultural
institutions is crucial it's a fight to
preserve Ukrainian freedom of expression
but it isn't simple especially in
occupied areas with museums in Harrison
danetsk and luhansk forced to seed
control of their collections to Russia
those ready reports of permanent damage
with the stealing of 2 300 year old
golden artifacts to the Looting of
paintings from mariopo's Museum